OF THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
IN RESPONSE THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERS
IN IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES. TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
BERLINGUER COMMITTEE HEARING IN
THE CAPITOL AND THERE ARE NO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS. AN EXTENSIVE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUAL WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE TO
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 THAT IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FIVE SIX ZERO TWO ZERO
FIVE AGAIN THAT IS. FIVE SIX
ZERO TWO ZERO FIVE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. AND FOR
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR. TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND PLEASE WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER AFTER
THAT. THERE MAY BE A SHORT WAIT
SO AGAIN PATIENCE IS IMPORTANT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND YOU'LL
BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. HE'S NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU CLEARLY. AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN YOU DO
CALL IN YOU ME IN THE PHONE OR
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING US
ON. SO YOU CAN TALK INTO THE
PHONE SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE. OBVIOUSLY ARE
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED SO I EXPECT
EVERYONE TO. BE A WELL. IT'S
ALSO A GOOD TIME TO REMIND
EVERYBODY PROVIDING TESTIMONY
THIS IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. SO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL. YOUR TESTIFYING ON AND
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY RE LITIGATING THE-
POLICY MERITS THAT YOU DIDN'T
POLICY COMMITTEE AND FOCUS ON
THE FISCAL PLEASE. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESS AND
THE CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
EIGHT BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
THREE OF THOSE ITEMS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR DO PASSED MOTION.
AND THE REST ARE FOUGHT
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON
THE BILL WILL ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SO MISTER CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
PORTANTINO I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
AND TINO PRESENT SENATOR BATES.
THE NEW BATES PRESENT SENATOR
BRADFORD HERE SENATOR BRADFORD
PRESENT SENATOR JONES. INTERCOM
LONGER HAIR INTERCOM WATER
PRESENT CENTER LAYERED HERE
SENATOR LAYERED PRESENT SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI HERE ANOTHER
LIKE HEALTH PRESENT. WEBER
QUORUM THANK YOU THANK YOU
JOINING US TODAY. DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARING WE ARE GOING
TO GIVE EACH SIDE WILL BE MATED
THREE MINUTES OF TOTAL TIME FOR
THEIR PRIMARY WITNESS TESTIMONY
NOW IF THEY DON'T HAVE PRIMARY
WITNESSES WERE GONNA GO RIGHT
TO THE MEAT TO TESTIMONY. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES IF NECESSARY WILL ALSO
LIMIT THIS ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
TO TWELVE MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE
AS A REMINDER ALL MID WITNESSES
SHOULD AGAIN LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY. TO THE PHYSICAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL AND THEN WE
GO TO THE ME TWO SECTIONS IT
WILL BE NAME AFFILIATION A
POSITION. AND THAT WILL BE
ENFORCED- I SEE DOCTOR WOULD
HERE. YOU HAVE WE ARE HERE WE
HAVE A BUNCH OF BILLS BEFORE WE
GET TO YOU. SO I JUST WANTED IN
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SIT HERE.
BECAUSE OF THE ONLINE PIECE WE-
DO EVERYTHING IN ORDER. YEAH
YOU'RE YOU'RE PROBABLY TIRED OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES AWAY. SO OKAY
THANK YOU SIR JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE. WE HAVE A MISTER CHOW'S.
AB THIRTY NINE HOLD ON ONE
SECOND. JUST GET ORGANIZED HERE
FOR SECOND. THAT'S ALL RIGHT
MISTER CHAIR IS A THIRTEEN.
WHICH IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
IT IS I THE CAL. CHIU CLIMATE.
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO'S WAY
PRESENTE SOME RIGHT PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
IN SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
NINE. HE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
MOMENT. OUR SYSTEM IS QUEUING
UP. OKAY THERE WITH AN OPERATOR
BE JUST SECOND FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY. ZERO AND OUR FIRST PRACTICE
WILL BE LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD MY. TWENTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR A
UNIVERSITY THAT. I WANT TO
TESTIFY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY NINE IT'S AN EXCELLENT
INVESTMENT- THAT WILL BE
RECOUPED MANY TIMES OVER NOT
JUST IN TERMS OF THE IMMEDIATE
MATTER FINDING THAT COMES IN
BUT OBVIOUSLY IN THE POTENTIAL
TO SAVE THE PLANET AND
CIVILIZATION AS WE KNOW IT.
THANK I HOPE YOU WILL. THANK
YOU THIS IS THE WE HADN'T
PRIMARY WITNESSES UP SO WE'RE
JUST TAKE NAME. ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. ANYONE ELSE ON
SUPPORTING AB THIRTY NINE. AS A
FINAL REMINDER TO SUPPORT AB
THIRTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MR HERE
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
SUPPORT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
TO SB. THIRTY NINE. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR AB THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE WON WITH AN OPERATOR.
AND WE WILL GO. GO TO LINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
TWENTY ONE. YOU WHAT OTHER
CALLER SPEAK SO I'M GOING TO
ASK FOR THIRTY SECONDS I'M IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY NINE
FROM A FISCAL PERSPECTIVE THIS
SEEMS TO BE A VERY QUESTIONABLE
TIME TO BE LEGISLATING ANY.
TRIED TO CUT HIM OFF HE KIND
WITH CHINA CLIMATE OR NOT THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE SUPPOSED SB.
THIRTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AMATEUR
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP AND FOR THE
RECORD THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY FOR
OR AGAINST AB THIRTY NINERS
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY. FORTY AS
WELL AND SO I BELIEVE WE HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH
US GOOD MORNING BIZANA DERA THE
OF A FILE. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOLLY EDITOR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE DON'T
HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION ON
THIS MEASURE- BUT WE DO CONCUR
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THE BILL
CURRENTLY IMPOSES MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE COSTS HOWEVER I
WOULD NOTE THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE INSTITUTE IS UNABLE TO
SECURE. CONTINUED PHILANTHROPIC
RESOURCES IN THE FUTURE
CODIFICATION OF ITS DUTIES
COULD RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES. IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES AND
HAVING HEARD FROM FINANCE I SEE
NO. HANDS OF MY COLLEAGUES GO
UP SO NO DISCUSSION SO AT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION S. AB THIRTY
NINE GO TO SUS. MOVING TO A
BEAT SEVEN SEVEN BY MR VIA DAR
ES DOMESTIC VICTIM. ADDRESS
CONTRA- THIS IS A SUSPENSE.
CANDIDATE AS WELL AND THE
AUTHOR WAY PER. AND SOCORRO TO
POWER TEST FOR DISCOVERED IN
FORTY- THREE YEARS IN ROOM
TWENTY FIVE. MODERATORS ARE IN
SUPPORT OF A TWO SEVEN ON THE
VAST VIOLENCE. ADR COMP. THE
SOCIAL FOR A BI TO SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. IN TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AB- TO SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE
THE PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE
QUEUE AND WE WILL GO WITH LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
TWENTY TWO. HI MY OFFICE AND
THIS WITH CAL CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE AND SOME. AND A
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WILL NOT GO
TO OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IN THIS COMPANY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE
MODERATOR WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN. BUSH POSE
AB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND NOBODY IS
KILLING UP. ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN A PORT SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO FINANCE
MIS ON IT THERE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE AN
APPROVED POSITION ON THIS BILL
WOULD NOTE THAT THE SECRETARY
OF STATE ESTIMATES COST A FIFTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
ADDITIONALLY WE KNOW THAT THE
BILL CREATES POTENTIAL FOR
EXPANDED USE OF THE SAFE AT
HOME PROGRAM. BUT A PROJECTION
OF THE EXPANDED USES
INDETERMINABLE AT THIS TIME. I
WOULD NOT THAT ANY REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES I WILL BE EVALUATED
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. FINALLY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL INDICATES ANY COSTS
RESULTING FROM THIS MEASURE
WOULD BE MINOR AN OBSERVABLE.
THANK YOU. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SINGLE GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN. WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON A. B.
FOUR FIVE THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA ON SEXUAL BATTERY NINETY.
CONDOM REMOVAL THIS ITEM IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHOR
IS WAY PRESENTATION. AND AS I
SAID IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF SUPPORTERS NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WISHING TO SUPPORT
AB FORTY TWO BUCKS TO ME EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY THREE. SHOW SUPPORT
FOR A BI FOR FIFTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME THE INITIAL SUPPORT
FOR A BI. A FIFTY THREE FOUR
FIFTY THREE EXCUSE ME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY'S GIVING UP
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
FOR AB FOUR FIFTY THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS OPEN
TWENTY. FORTY MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FOUR FIFTY THREE.
SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR
A. B. FOUR FIVE THREE.
STRUCTURE LOANS QUEUING UP ALL
RIGHT TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION- WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE
AN APPROVED POSITION ON THIS
MEASURE- BUT NOT THAT WE DO NOT
ANTICIPATE AND FISCAL IMPACT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS MEASURE. HOWEVER TO
THE EXTENT THE BILL ADDS TO
TRIAL COURT'S CASELOAD. OF
COURT BACKLOGS MAY INCREASE IN
COULD CREATE BACK PRESSURE THE
GENERAL FUND TO HANDLE THE
INCREASED CASELOAD- TO THE
STATE COURTS BUT COURTS DO NOT
KEEP RECEIVE. ON A WORKLOAD.
AND THEREFORE LESS DESPERATE TO
CASE LOAD BECAUSE SICKENING-
AND CAN BE DOCKING. IT'S LIKELY
BE A SORT. THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATE JUST ONE WAY TIME I
WANT TO MAKE I GAVE OPPORTUNITY
BOTH AND- FOR A BEFORE. FIFTY
THREE. SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. FOUR FIFTY
THREE. PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO.
NOBODY IS KILLING UP ALL RIGHTS
HAVE A TAKEN FOR OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITY AND SING QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FOR FIFTY THREE.
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO
AB FOR SEVENTY TWO BY MR COOLEY
CAMPSITE RESERVATIONS SECURING
AN EQUITABLE PROCESS. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MISSED CLUES
WAVE PRESENT AND MS BONNER
HARBATH FIVE PRESENTATION. AND
WE WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONIES. NOBODY IN THIS
THERE'S NO INTO FORTY MODERATE
IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORT OF AB. FOUR SEVEN TWO.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR A BI FOR
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI. FOR
SEVENTY TWO. I'M NOT AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION OF AB.
FOUR SEVEN TWO. CHAU OPPOSITION
FOR A BEFORE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZEROS ON OPERATOR
CAN GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR AB. FOUR SEVEN
TWO. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
APARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T CURRENTLY
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS MEASURE
I WOULD KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS RECREATION
ESTIMATES THE BILL CREATES THE
NEED FOR TWO ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS WITH DOCTOR OF. THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND AN ANNUAL
ONGOING COST OF THREE INTERNET
LEVIN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY PARKS ESTIMATES TO
ADDITIONAL PERMANENT POSITIONS
WOULD BE REQUIRED IF THE NEED
FOR ONGOING ENFORCEMENT ARISES-
WOULD KNOW THAT THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT. I GIVEN
THIS IS OF THE ON EFFORTS TO
REDUCE PROHIBITING OF THE REST
OF SYSTEM. AND ANY REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES WILL BE EVALUATED FOR
THE ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS. IN
TASTIC. HAVING HEARD FROM.
FORMER FINANCE SINCE NO HE GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION FOUR SEVEN
TWO WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
AB FOR FIVE SIX BY SOME MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND MISUSE OF SPERM
OVER AN EMBRYO DAMAGES- THIS IS
AB FIVE FIVE SO AFTER WAVE.
VOTER SUPPORT TO THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE WISHING TO IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FIVE FIVE SIX. DO I IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIVE SIX
PLEASE ONE FOR BY. INITIAL
SUPPORT FOR A BI FIVE FIVE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. NOBODY
IS GOING UP MR CARE. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION OF AB
FIVE FIVE SIX. THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FIVE FIVE SIX. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB FIVE FIVE
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE FIVE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NO PART TO SPENT QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO FINANCE.
YOUR CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE AN
APPROVED POSITION ON THIS
MEASURE I WOULD NOTE THAT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THIS BILL ADDS
TO THE TRIAL COURT'S CASELOAD
THAT BACKLOGS MAY INCREASE AND
COULD CREATE PRESSURE ON THE
GENERAL FUND TO HANDLE THIS
INCREASED WORKLOAD. BUT THE
COURTS DO NOT TYPICALLY RECEIVE
FUNDING ON A WORKLOAD BASIS
THEREFORE LESS THIS PARTICULAR
CASE- BECOME SIGNIFICANT IT
WILL LIKELY BE ABSORBED. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU HEARD FINING.
AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION THING NO
HANDS GO WITHOUT A- AB FOR FIVE
SIX. WILL GO TO SUSPEND. THE
PREVIOUS OUR FIRST. BILL TO BE
PRESENTED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
BERMAN. AB TEN. ON ARCHITECTS
CONTINUING. WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COME ON UP AND TELL US
ABOUT YOUR BILL. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
PRIMARY WITNESS ON THE
COASTLINE MIKE BELOW. WITH THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. AND WE'LL YES THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL AND PLEASE
TELL US ABOUT YOUR THE FISCAL
IMPACT TO YOUR BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN SANDERS CLIMATE
SCIENTISTS AGREE THAT OUR
SOCIETY MUST PREPARE FOR A ZERO
CARBON FUTURE NOW. BUT CURRENT
CONTINUING EDUCATION FOR
ARCHITECTS IS LIMITED TO
DISABILITY ACCESS MEANING THAT
MANY PROFESSIONALS MAY HAVE
LITTLE. TO NO STRATEGIES FOR
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN CONSTRUCTION. FOR
A BI TEN TEN WOULD REQUIRE THAT
ARCHITECTS LICENSED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COMPLETE
FIVE HOURS OF ZERO NET CARBON
CONTINUING EDUCATION PER TWO
YEAR RENEWAL CYCLE. THIS BILL
COMES FROM THE ARCHITECTURAL
COMMUNITY ASKING THAT WE IMPOSE
THE ADDITIONAL DUTIES THE COST
OF WHICH WILL BE BORNE BY THE
PROFESSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN. AND MR BELOW ARE YOU
HERE. I AM MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MIKE HELLO FOR THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS
CALIFORNIA- WE ARE THE SPONSOR
THE BILL WE THINK- THE ZERO NET
CARBON IS THE DESIGN. ISSUE OF
THE OF OUR TIME YOU KNOW IT
APPLIES TO EVERY ELEMENT OF THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT RESIDENTIAL
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL PUBLIC
PRIVATE- SOME ARCHITECTS ARE
MANY DECADES OUT OF SCHOOL. OF
COURSE THE ARCHITECTURE SCHOOLS
ARE TEACHING US. BUT WE THINK
IT'S CRITICAL THAT ALL
ARCHITECTS HAVE AT LEAST THE
GROUNDING IN THE SUBJECT. WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS BOARD AND
ARE TOLD THAT THIS CAN BE ADDED
ON TO THE EXISTING C. E.
REQUIREMENTS ON ACCESS. IN A
SIMPLE AND INEXPENSIVE WAY SO
WE DON'T SEE IT AS A BIG FISCAL
ISSUE. AND WE WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL GO TO ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY ME TO THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THIS COVERED IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO SUPPORT AB. TEN TEN.
TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
TEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN AN OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE AND
THEN PLACE IT BACK IN THE
QUEUE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI TEN CAN'T.
AND WE DO HAVE A PERSON QUEUED
UP AND THAT WILL ALIGN TWENTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
THREE. FIND TWENTY THREE. BUT
YOU. OH WELL THIS IS A TERRIBLE
BILL BUT THIS IS NOT THE ONE
I'M LISTENING FOR AB TEN TEN
IT'S A TEN THANK YOU. OKAY.
ANYONE ELSE INTO OF AB. TWO
TEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
THANK YOU MISTER. NOW YOU DON'T
WANT TO TAKE OUTLINED AGAIN DO
YOU THAT'S THE SAME PERSON NOT
ON NOT ON THAT BILL IF SHE
WANTS TO COME ON ANOTHER BILL
WILL HAPPY TO HAPPY NEW YEAR.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR- IT
SHOWING SUPPORT FOR A BI. TEN
TEN. AND NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
OUR I WILL NOT OPPOSITION AB
TEN TEN THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. BUT WE DO
HAVE- ANYBODY ON THE LINE
OPPOSED. SHOW ALL TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. TENSION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. I SHOULD
KEEP **** UP BUT I'LL JUST.
WAIT TILL SHE'S VERY GOOD AT
THE BILL. WELL IF SHE WANTS TO
TESTIFIED THIS WHAT WE CAN TAKE
HER. GIVE HER LOCATE PLEASE
CALL AT EIGHT ONE. ONE TWO
THREE AT ONE ZERO AGAIN. AND
OUT OF WILL OPEN LINE TO THREE
PLEASE GO. YOUR HONOR BELL I'M
OPPOSED THAT BUT IT'S ALWAYS A
LOT WHEN I LIVE TO YOU. BECAUSE
THIS A TERROR BLOW WELL PLEASE
NOTE RECORD NO ON AB FOR SEVEN
TWO NOT ON A ONE ZERO ZERO AND.
HERBAL CHIU BILL MAKING HEALTH
CHINESE CLIMB IN. IS A BUNCH
THE S. CHINA CALL THIS BUYER
AND WE DON'T NEED STRONGER
RELAY. WITH THE MODERATE. ON A.
THIRTY NINE. NOBODY ELSE IS
GOING ON. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO FINANCE AND THEN MISTER
WHITE CASKEY HAS A QUESTION.
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITY FOR
LEVITY FOR MR BERMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE AN
APPROVED POSITION ON THIS BILL
THIS TIME- THE CALIFORNIA
ARCHITECTS BOARD ESTIMATES IT
WILL INCUR INITIAL A ONE TIME
COST OF TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS. CORRECT
REGULATIONS WORKLOAD AND
ONGOING ANNUAL COST OF EIGHTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
AUDITING AND ENFORCEMENT
WORKLOAD. AT THIS. IT MAY BE
ABLE TO ABSORB THIS COST BUT
NOTES THAT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
MAY BE NEEDED IF ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS ARE HIGHER
THAN ESTIMATED. FINALLY THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES THE OFFICE
OF INFORMATION SERVICES WILL
OCCUR FINALLY MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE COST TO ADD A NEW
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT FOR LICENSE RENEWAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE STRIKE
OUT HERE YEAH I GUESS FOR
FINANCE HOW DID THE
ARCHITECTURAL BOARD GET THE
EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
CONCERT ALREADY AUDITING
ARCHITECTS AND THEY MUST HAVE
OTHER. OR MAYBE I MISUNDERSTAND
IT THERE'S NO OTHER COURSE
REQUIREMENTS OTHER THAN THE
FIVE HOURS OF THE ADA TRAINING
SO THEY'RE JUST DOING. IT'S A
ONE TRICK PONY AND OTHER DUE TO
TRICKS. IS THAT. IS THAT. THE.
THE END OF A BASIS OF THE S.
THANK YOU SENATOR- I HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
QUESTION I WOULD NOTE AS WITH
ANY REQUESTS FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ACOSTA IS A SEPARATE
REVIEW AND APPROVAL THROUGH THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS THAT WE
WOULD CERTAINLY- YOU'RE DOING
THERE- BUT YOU CHANGE PROPOSAL
ASSOCIATED. WITH ANY ADDITIONAL
REQUEST FOR THE THEY'RE NOT
EXPECTING TO HAVE ANYMORE
ARCHITECTS ARE ALREADY AUDITING
THE WORLD OF ARCHITECTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEY WHICH IS.
WHATEVER THE HOWEVER ONE OUT OF
TEN ONE OUT OF FIFTEEN OR
WHATEVER IT IS HOW LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM YOU THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES BERMAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I COULDN'T
POSSIBLY ADD ANYTHING TO IT
DISCOURSE WHO HAD- HERE RESPECT
PASSED PRIVATE. GOOD CLOTHES. I
WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION IS TO
DO PASSED TODAY ASSEMBLY
FICTION THE SENATE FLOOR
ANYBODY WANNA MAKE A MOTION.
HOUSE I CAN MOVED BY SENATOR Y.
CASKEY MISTER CHIEF CONSULT
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO HIS SENATOR BATES.
BATES NOT VOTING CENTER
BRADFORD OUR CENTER BRADFORD HI
SENATOR JONES. JONES NO SENATOR
CON LOGGER HI THE COME LONGER I
CENTER LAYERED HI LAYERED I
CENTER Y. CASKEY HI. MICHALSKI
I. THOSE FIVE TO ONE THE BILL
IS OUT FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN THEY
DON'T. THE VERY PATIENT DOCTOR
WOULD IF YOU WOULD COME ON UP
AND OUT YOUR HEALTH COMMITTEE
BILL ON HEALTH AB FIFTY FIVE
AGAIN THIS IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. SO WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR PLEASE TELL
US ABOUT YOUR BILL THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS INDEED
A COMMITTEE HEALTH COMMITTEE
BILL NOT MY PERSONAL BILL- THIS
BILL PROPOSES UP FOR PART
PROVIDES FOR TO NECESSARY
TECHNICAL FIXES FIRST IT
EXPANDS THE CURRENT DEFINITION
OF AN INFECTION PREVENTION AND
PREVENTION IS. EMPLOYED BY
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY TO
INCLUDE PERSON TO INCLUDE
PERSONS WHO HAVE PROFESSIONAL
TRAINING SUCH AS A LICENSED
NURSE MEDICAL TECHNOLOGIST
MICROBIOLOGISTS EPIDEMIOLOGISTS
HOTEL PROFESSIONAL OR OTHER
HEALTH CARE RELATED FIELDS. AND
A COMPLETED SPECIALIZED
TRAINING IN INFECTION
PREVENTION CONTROL THIS IS
NECESSARY TO CLEAN UP FROM AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR FROM LAST
YEAR WHICH INADVERTENTLY
PREVENTED SOME QUALIFIED
PROFESSIONALS WHO CURRENTLY
WORK IN HOSPITALS FROM BEING
EMPLOYED BY SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. SECOND IT EXTENDS
THE DUE DATE FROM JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO JANUARY
TWENTY ONE JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BY WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AS REQUIRED TO
ADOPT REGULATIONS. RELATED TO
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES
HOLE CHIP HOLD HOLD CHILD CARE
MODEL. IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
RULEMAKING REQUIREMENTS. OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT.
I'M CURRENTLY WORKING WITH T.
PH ON A MAN'S I WILL TAKE ON
THE FLOOR TO FIND THE I. P.
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS SO THE
BILL WILL NO LONGER NEED.
REGULATIONS FOR IMPLEMENTATION
WHICH WILL THEREFORE REDUCE THE
COST I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR THAT LET'S
GO YOU HAVE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES I DON'T BELIEVE. AND
SO WE'LL GO TO ARE. ME TOO'S
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SUPPORT. AB. FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
FILED BY. ZERO AND AT THIS TIME
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM AND THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTIES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE. SO
OPPOSITION FOR A BI FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FILED BY
ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION. NOBODY
IS QUEUING UP. R. I'D HAVE A
TAKE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION-
I DO NOT BELIEVE FINANCING
ORTEGA ARGUE HAVE A FILE ON
THIS ONE BUSINESS YEAR THANK
YOU. WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES IT WOULD REQUIRE ONE
LIMITED TERM POSITION AT A COST
OF ONE HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ANNUALLY OVER
THREE YEARS FROM THE LICENSING
AND CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FUND.
AND WOULD NOTE THAT AGAIN ANY
REQUEST FOR RESOURCES THAT WILL
BE REVIEWED AS PART OF THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS. LASTLY
THE PROP DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICE. AND SEVERAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED. WITH IMPLEMENTING
THIS LEGISLATION. THANK YOU.
MISTER WOULD OUR DOCTOR WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE MY FOR MY
FAVORITE VERSION OF A CLOSE
SEEING NO QUESTIONS IS THERE
MOTION THIS IS A DO PASSED THE
SENATE FLOOR. SMOOVE BY MR WHY
CASCADE MISTER CONSOLE WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES RIGHT BATES HIS
CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
AYES SENATOR JONES JONES HIS
SENATOR COM LONGER HI I'M
LONGER ALLIES CENTER LAYERED HI
LAYERED HIS SENATOR Y. CASKEY
HI. I CAN SKI BY. VOTED SEVEN
TO ZERO BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO
THANK YOU FOR BEING PATIENT
DOCTOR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HAVE
A GOOD DAY WE HAVE ONE FINAL
ITEMS- WHICH I WILL BE
PRESENTING ITS ONE OF THE
CLAIMS BILLS OF MISTAKES YOU
HAVE THE SCRIPT. I BELIEVE
IDEAS- ARE YOU OKAY YES AND A
DIRECT FROM HERE. IF ALL RIGHTS
SLEAZE. ALL RIGHT I'M
PRESENTING AB FIFTEEN NINETY
THREE WHICH IS NE OF THE-
CLAIMS BILLS FROM THE VICTIM'S
COMPENSATION BOARDS- BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ- SAID
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES THIS
BILL WOULD APPROPRIATE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OF THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD FOR THE
PAYMENT OF FIVE STATE CLAIMS
RELATED TO THE RONI'S
CONVICTIONS OF DEREK HARRIS
JEREMY POCKET ARTURO YOU GIVEN
AS- ROBERT FENNER BACH AND-
ANDREW WILSON. THE BILL ALSO
INCLUDES A MINOR PROCREATION OF
1-100-010-0406 DOLLARS IN STATE
FUNDS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO RE ISSUE
THREE EXPIRED ST CHECKS THAT
WERE NEVER CASHED IN EACH OF
THESE AROUND HIS CONVICTION
CASES THE COURT SET ASIDE THE
CONVICTIONS AND MADE A FINDING
OF FACTUAL INNOCENCE BORDERS
APPROVED THE CLAIMS AND
RECOMMEND AN APPROPRIATE.
APPROPRIATION TO COVER THE
PAYMENTS I HAVE NEIL ANNIS FOR
THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD
HERE ON THE COAST LINE AS A
SPORT WITNESS IS AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE AMMONIUS CONVICTION CLAIMS
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO DO HAVE THE PRIMARY
WITNESS I BELIEVE HE'S ON THE
LINE OUR MODERATOR. ARE YOU
SHOWING HIM ON THE LINE. PLEASE
A BONEHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
MISTER ENNIS IS A REMINDER WE
DO ALLOW JUST THREE MINUTES
TOTAL FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESS
SO PLEASE NOTE THAT IN YOUR OP
PRESENTATION THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING NEIL IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE COORDINATOR FOR THE
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD AND
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT AMONG
THESE CONNECTION COMES. I DON'T
SEE ANY ON. QUESTIONS ARE GOING
HEAD SENATOR WIECKOWSKI I THANK
YOU MADAM ACTING CHAIR OUR VICE
CHAIR I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
FINANCE I'M ON THE FIRST PAGE
FOR ANALYSIS AND THIS THIS
LEGISLATION IS SEEKING A
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR D. G. S.
R. D. T. V. S. TI RE ISSUE. A
CHECK THAT THEY ARE THERE THEY
RECEIVE FROM THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION FOR SOME SECURITY
RELEASES IT TO US. UNEXPIRED
CHECKS WHICH ONE CHECK THEY
WANT A THOUSAND BUCKS TO ISSUE
THE CHECK. WHICH IS INCREDIBLE
TO ME I'M I'M FLABBERGASTED AS
pLINE THE D. D. M. V. IS
CHARGING SEVENTY THREE DOLLARS
TO RE ISSUE CHECKS TO GIVE IT
TO- DGS HOW COME WE HAVE SUCH A
DISPARITY. IN WHY SHOULD THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PAY FOR.
DGS ABOUT BUCKS WHO IS RIGHT
NOW CHECK. FINANCE THANK YOU
SENATOR I IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THOSE IN THE AMOUNTS OF
THE CHECKS TO BE REISSUED NOT
NOT THE COST TO ISSUE THE
CHECKS THEMSELVES. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. THEN WE WILL GO TO
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- I DO NOT SEE ANYONE.
CORRECT I'M SORRY DID YOU HAVE
SOMETHING ELSE TO SAY SENATOR
WIECKOWSKI. I'M SORRY IN A WE
WILL GO TO THOSE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE HERE IN THIS ROOM
AND- NO ONE IN OUR ROOM ON.
FORTY TWO OF TWENTY FORTY- DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE IT
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
MISTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
A BI FIFTEEN NINETY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BEEF. ONE FIVE
NINE THREE. AND WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP. THEN
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THOSE ARE
WITH SEEK WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AND I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE HERE IN THIS ROOM- NORI
IN. TWENTY FORTY THEN LET US GO
TO THE PHONE LINES AND MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
AREN'T WAITING ON THE LINE THAT
WHICH IS TO. FAR TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN NINETY
THREE. THAT'S WHY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB FIFTEEN NINETY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
ZERO. WE HAVE NOBODY QUEUEING
UP. YOU KNOW AND THEN WE'LL GO
TO WE HAD A COMMENT FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD DO
THEY LIKE TO ADD ANY ADDITION
TO ANSWERING OUR FURNITURE
WHITE HOUSE KEYS QUESTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NO I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MISSION. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THEN ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO ASK A
QUESTION OR MAKE A COMMENT. ON
THIS BILL THEN WE'LL GO BACK TO
SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR CLOTHES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
WILL. DO WE HAVE A MOTION FOR A
BI. FIFTEEN NINETY THREE. MOVED
BY SENATOR WHITE COUNTY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BY STATE I CENTER BRADFORD ARE
BRADFORD HIS SENATOR JONES
JONES I SENATOR COME LONGER HI
COME LONGER EYES CENTER
LAYERED- LAYERED- ICE CENTER BY
CAL SKI. HI LIKE I THE BILL
SEVEN ZERO. THIRTY SEVEN ZERO
ON THAT BILL THANK YOU I DO NOT
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANYTHING ON
CALL SO THAT THE INCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS THANK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IN MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BEING HERE- IF
YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA AND THIS COMMITTEE OF
APPROPRIATIONS IS. ADJOURNED.